now will ferrell knows a thing or two
about campfire chaos on the big screen
but when he's not working will is busy
working for good and you know what as
that charity has grown so his Will's
career and there have been so many
magical moments best part of your SNL
days not throwing away the cash I tried
it once earlier that year it didn't work
at the Tate read-through and I brought
it back because we were walking I ruined
his career
I couldn't used a little more cowbell
will revisited the cowbell sketch on
stage at LA's Greek Theatre interrupting
a performance by Coldplay's Chris Martin
who is one of the many famous faces
supporting cancer for college cancer for
college is a charity very close to wills
heart it was started 25 years ago by his
college fraternity brother Craig Pollard
who is a two-time cancer survivor
Craig battled the disease when he and
will were College sophomores at USC it
forced me to take an inventory of my
life at a very young age to find out
what you know impact I was making in the
world that impact has been major events
like this one have raised more than 3
million dollars in scholarships to
cancer survivors hoping to go to college
there's so much focus obviously on
getting through surviving cancer that a
lot of families they don't have
resources for college will has been a
part of the cancer for college
organization from the start and has
brought countless celebs to the cause
act the event this weekend wills Ron
Burgundy made a special appearance and
was joined by James Corden Jimmy Kimmel
and Conan O'Brien because the fundraiser
was called Will Ferrell's best night of
your life
we just had to ask about some of his
best moments best part of making the
movie elf getting to wear yellow tights
for 75 days of shooting
sorry that's part of dressing up as Ron
Burgundy
the Canadian curling Finals Ron actually
got to do the commentary with the real
announcers I saw this shot once
completed in 72 best part of being a
father asking them 20 times a day to
clean up their clothes and turn off
lights they wasted a lot of energy
doesn't tell the boys to go to bed it's
his wife who carries the hammer come on
down
[Music]
[Applause]